Jordan Peterson was on Piers Morgan's
show and Piers asked Jordan to give an
assessment of Donald Trump and I think
this is worth watching I thought it was
very fair Donald Trump what is he is he
a narcissist a sociopath a psychopath
all of those things none of them
I don't think that he's a psychopath
um because he's been successful in
repeated Enterprises over long periods
of time and he has a variety of people
who are remain intensely loyal to him
it's very easy to demonize someone that
you don't approve of let's say and
certainly Trump is being subject I would
say to more demonization than any
political leader in the west that I can
remember in my entire lifetime including
Richard Nixon and so that's also set him
back on his heels and made him somewhat
embattled in defensive which I don't
think did any great things for
for his personality in some real sense
the good doctor a very few analyze
things better than him let me just
reiterate a couple things so he said
that Donald Trump is not a psychopath
right you watch mainstream media the
guy's a psychopath he's Hitler too blah
blah blah that he said he's been
successful where there's no doubt that
Trump has been successful over long
periods of time in many different
businesses he's had many businesses fail
too but he's still standing the Trump
name means something right that's true
he has loyalty especially with the base
obviously uh and then I what he said
there at the end that he's been more
demonized than anyone and that that
could then have an effect on Trump's uh
sort of attitude and behavior I thought
was very interesting so they continued
to talk about this and then Piers Morgan
brought up if there was a better
alternative than Donald Trump and now
you'll see why I'm connecting all of
this to the post-election situation that
we're in would you like him to run again
would it be good for America do you
think
no I don't think it would be good for
America would it be good for him to run
that's a diff that's a difficult
question because it might be that it
would be good for America to have
whether or not Donald Trump should be
president sorted out in the public
sphere debated intensely and subject to
an election so it might be very
interesting to see him put himself
forward on the Republican ticket if I
had my druthers
um and I say this I hope with due care I
would rather see someone like DeSantis
step forward who shares some of that
forthright
strength let's say that characterizes
Trump at his best but seems to be a more
uh cautious administrator and a less
divisive figure I think that would be
better
man I can't believe I do it with the guy
he's that good I still hear him now and
I think man if I could just explain
things the way he does I mean there's a
there's a beauty to the way he describes
these things first off the way he
cautions things right like maybe the
battle should happen right like as
opposed to just indicting Trump pushing
Trump off into the corner ignoring the
base all of those things demonizing half
the country maybe the guys should run so
that the battle could be had out in the
open and people could see what the ideas
are see people could really see what the
tactics are he's saying maybe that would
be best but then he is saying that there
is another guy who has seemingly much of
the upside of trump on the policies and
the ideas and all of that and doesn't
have the downside is more disciplined is
more competent Etc so obviously that is
Ron DeSantis